we previously talked about dim diplomats
coming to Washington DC and staying at
Donald Trump's a relatively new
Washington DC hotel we've known that for
months last week we heard and learned
that the State Department was
recommending you could call it
suggesting you could call it encouraging
foreign dignitaries on official visits
to Washington DC to stay Donald Trump's
Washington DC hotel and now Donald
Trump's endlessly articulate and
graceful press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders promoted Donald
Trump's Hawaii hotel during a
conversation with the press Trump has
been or was at the time on route to Asia
and on route to Asia he stopped in
Hawaii and during the stop in Hawaii
Donald Trump went to the Trump Hotel in
Waikiki he supposedly had separated from
his businesses this was an official trip
so Sarah Huckabee Sanders was correctly
asked Trump supposedly wasn't involved
with his businesses anymore or with his
former employees whatever would the
entire thing and this was an official
trip
why did Donald Trump go to his hotel in
Waikiki Hawaii and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders said well it has been a
tremendously successful project and he
wanted to say hello and thank you to the
employees for all their hard work this
is sort of like a product placement
right she's editorializing that it has
been tremendously successful I would
actually like on Sarah Huckabee Sanders
is podium a light that turns on that
says sponsored by or product placement
whenever one of the Trump
cash-generating ventures is mentioned
why is Trump meeting with employees that
he isn't even supposed to be involved
with as president of the United States
and the idea that it's just a visit that
it has no effect is silly right Trump
shows up the hotels and properties end
up in the news pictures are taken this
has a direct impact on business at every
single one of these locations and and in
the end Trump knows that he owns them or
in some cases he's just licensing his
name to them but either way Trump knows
that Trump hotels exists
and that they are his or ways that his
family makes money former White House
Ethics chief norm Eisen says pretty
simply this is an ethics violation
tweeting ethics violation by the press
secretary under 5 CFR 26:35 702 can't
promote Trump's businesses same
violation as Kellyanne Conway committed
and that's a reference to we covered
this months ago when Kellyanne Conway
promoted Trump's daughter Ivanka Trump's
fashion line on Fox News from inside the
White House press briefing room remember
when President Jimmy Carter had to put
his peanut farm in Georgia in a blind
trust to avoid a possible appearance of
a conflict of interest that was nothing
compared to this and the truth is that
mere possible constitutional violations
of the emoluments clause they're barely
going to register when it is scandal
after scandal when it is indictments at
the highest levels of trumps own
administration and campaign staffers and
in the end we go back to the question we
always have with Sarah Huckabee Sanders
which is is she even telling the truth
right this was sort of lost in the
shuffle until I just thought about it is
this a tremendously successful hotel
Sarah Huckabee Sanders lies so much that
even referring to this as a successful
hotel might be part of the lie I don't
know I quite frankly don't care but yet
more ethics concerns coming from Trump
staffers and Trump funneling cash into
his businesses that of course he knows
he still owns or is connected to